there's a word in Korean
it means providence
or fate
do you believe in that that's just
something Koreans say to seduce someone
[Music]
what a good story this is
childhood sweethearts who reconnect 20
years later and realized they were meant
for each other and the story I would be
the evil white American husbands
standing in the way of Destiny shut up
there's just this kid in my head for
such a long time I think I just missed
him did he miss you
his song
[Music]
I'm really sure
makes me feel like
the guy flew 13 hours to be here I'm not
gonna tell you that you can't see him or
something
[Music]
if two strangers walk by each other in
the street and their clothes
accidentally brushed
that means there have been 8 000 layers
of inia
between them
[Music]
want you to stay
please